نحن الان في دوار زريه والحقيقه امام حاله
تبدو مستعجله للسيده مصابه قابلتها قبل
دقائق يعني صدفه ونحن فقط نتفقد المنطقه
وكانت تبدو في طريقها لجلب بعض المساعدات
قبل ان نلاحظ بان المشيه غير طبيعيه بانها
ربما تعاني من مشاكل صحيه حينما اقتربت
شعرت بانها فعلا في حاله سيئه فهذه السيده
تعاني من الام شديده منذ ان حدث الزلزال
يعني منذ اربعه ايام وهي تقاوم هذه الحاله
لا تتنفس بشكل عادي لا تتمشى بشكل عادي
لديها الام يعني شديده جدا احتراماتي الله
يخليك
[موسيقى]
ايوه بالضبط احنا حدا ذاك الملعب ديال
الكره
[موسيقى]
مضروبه بزاف
ننتظر ان تنزل المروحيه في هذا المكان
الان القوات المسلحه تطلب ان نقترب نحاول
تقريب زهره
بخصوص المروحيه يبدو ان هناك حالات
مستعجله اخرى والمروحيات مشغوله في حالات
ربما اكثر
يعني استعجالا من حاله الخاله زهره يجب ان
نتسلق
ولا يريدون المغامره بحملها بفراش انه اذا
سقطت ستحدث كارثه
بسم الله بسم الله
[موسيقى]
وصلت سياره الاسعاف تمكنت من العبور وهيها
هنا وصلت لله الحمد
[موسيقى]
لله نحن الان في سيارات اسعاف يعني
الاسعاف تمكن من الوصول
حتى لم يساعدونا يعني في استحابنا كذلك
توجه ان شاء الله نحو المستشفى حتى تتسرق
زهره اول العلاجات
[موسيقى]